[Music]
hello and welcome to chess and
psychology
i was inspired today to come to the
chess club
and i'm very glad that ben was available
for that um
i have some cool queen sacrifices to
share with you
and i am a little
uh unhappy that's not snowing in san
luis so that's another reason i'm
wearing this
cool snowy kind of vibe
maybe it will inspire the weather to
snow i like snow i'm not the biggest fan
of rain
yeah sorry guys today we don't have any
gmpg
gmp is very occupied with his um
friend um the cat stray cat
behind the window so i didn't want to
disturb him
and i don't know how it would go if i
bring him to the chess club so i don't
want to risk that just yet
he's very well trained but at the same
time he
does what he wants so he might as well
just be walking around here
and i yeah i like my hair i want to stay
them
i want to keep them on my head okay so
today we have a bunch of queen
sacrifices
um at least three i will be reading a
chat through here and i'm also looking
at
well i'm presenting from here so should
go fun i got my red bull i have new tea
that i've kind of grown fond of so
i have everything ready for a fun day i
have three uh queen sacrifices
i'm hoping we'll get to at least two of
them two of them
are games of world champion and one of
them
is uh virus jaw who i hope he'll become
a world champion
at some point in my lifetime but
all right let's go ahead and get started
so another thing that i wanted to talk
about when we are looking at these games
is
that all three of these games are
something that
my brother has worked on and
we plan to present them ideally in the
book that we have
together we are writing a book which
hopefully will be out before march the
most of the content of it is done we
just have to work on the organization
and the chaptering of it so
that was another great news that i
wanted to share he is
a very um he's he is kind of the
backbone of it he's the analyzing boy
um uh he's he's been working so hard on
it
and um well it's
we're cooperating and we're co-authoring
but these three games was
mainly just him so i do want to give
credit to him so if borna if you watch
this thank you
and yeah i see there are some comments
about my cat
not being able to show up sorry about
that
you will probably see him tomorrow when
i stream at
home or playing the viewers that should
be fun
this it should be available digital i
have not
worked out the logistics of it but we
are working with um
thinking publishers and they are great
um some of my other friends have
published books with them everybody have
had
extremely pleasant experience with them
and yeah so um
okay so i see people are yep that is
great
i i will be sure to ask my publisher to
have it available
as pdf i'm sure it will be anyways
are you guys ready for fisher all right
let's go ahead so this game
i'm assuming that the concept of queen
sacrifice should give out
a little bit of the result
but i really enjoyed this game because
well
fisher was really well we all know how
talented he was
but the point is that it only took him
23 moves to
wrap up this game and he was extremely
like
brilliant in this game and well he
usually is but this game was just
phenomenal um so
this is uh well to be fair i don't
always play this king's indian i have
given it a few tries and i do enjoy it
but it's not my to-go opening my two
opening uh usually
is either nimzo indian or groomfeld
or just normal queens gambits
i see a lot of different states and
different the
different lots of different countries so
thank you i am reading the chats but
um oh it might be peter
you you can ta for me but don't give out
moves
all right so um one thing that i didn't
really understand was this idea with
e5 but like it's it's i feel like it's a
trap
like easily uh fischer easily could have
like played d6 to stop this idea but he
went and he kind of was provoking this
e5
and opponents kind of um kind of fell
for it
so it's it's not well
it's not exactly a gift e5 but
i do think that e5 when you're playing
fisher and
might definitely have um
have strong feelings for this position
because once
when an international playing of the
world champion and he gets to
push his king to ea it pushes knight to
e8 it's definitely
uh can be interesting gaining so much
space
um well be careful not to go knight h5
you can get g4
that's the one square not to go and
so now we're just continuing fischer is
just continuing to try and break through
and he's simply trying to
um deal with these super advanced pawns
however this c5 is also coming up
and well my question to you guys
now what should black do do you think
dtak c5 is a good idea oh greeting from
norway
i've only been to norway once but i
really did enjoy it
um how did i study my openings
um well it's kind of i i have a very
i kind of know my style so that's
something that helps me a lot i know my
style is if i'm get if i get into a
boring position
i can't play well and um so i try to
find my i try to prepare and um get
games that
are as active as possible i like having
a lot of space
so playing some opening like morocci is
ideal for me and that's something that i
was also talking about today
in the chess camps that we had so i i
think
if you know your chest style that's
going to help you a lot in deciding on
what opening to play
all right so i see a lot of ideas with
queen a5 oh and i see a lot of familiar
names
thank you for coming back queen five is
definitely um
worth considering but my problem with
queen a5 is
simply take and after
take uh then there is this queen d5
and do you guys really like this
position because i'm
not very uh i don't really feel it it's
like i don't
i feel like white has an easier game so
i don't think it's worth
uh considering queen well it's worth
considering but it's not really worth um
spending so much time and obsessing over
should i actually go this
uh do you really want to get into that
position with the queen d5 so i don't
think that's a good idea
anything else how else can we develop
keep in mind we can't take it because
we're going to drop the queen
any other way of developing
thank you yo yeah i think um knight c6
is great
well peter uh sorry uh pt i don't think
that's a bad idea you can
you can still um try to
think and answer as to the best of their
abilities you can still try to come up
with
ways to develop ways to make your pieces
better you might
not be able to do as good of a
calculation as
maybe 1800 or 2000 does but you can
still
have the greatest understanding yep
let's get this knight up here
uh now we could want to take over here
now that our queen is defended no more
dropping the queen
we want to sacrifice the coin we don't
want to blunder it
so in the game opponent simply took we
take back
and white played knight e4 do you think
this is a good idea
and if not what else do you think white
should have done
no thank you pt well i've been there
sometimes calculation can take a lot out
of you but
if you actually understand the position
and if you develop your
chess understanding that's something
that's everybody can do
calculation sometimes might be very
tricky
i feel that
so all right so i see there is that idea
that if
knight e4 queen a5 is possible okay
um it is definitely possible nothing
wrong with that
[Music]
let's see oh hello amir ali
uh developing knight to f3 i agree so
instead of knight e4 uh bishop f5 is
another a good idea queen a5 is also
doable
and then you could try to go for bishop
f5 so for example if queen a5 queen d2
take take
and then you take over here and uh
bishop f5 also coming up
or you could just take over here with
ideal bishop of five so i kind of
the problem of knight e4 is that's kind
of dropping
a lot of things first of all uh the pawn
drops with queen a5
second of all if fischer um
doesn't really care for that pawn as he
didn't in the game bishop f5 is the
second choice
so if you give your opponent the chance
to actually have multiple good moves
that's not exactly um the best way to do
it you know
now in the game of white point knight g3
let me go a little
back and here knight e4 is not a good
move as he kind of agreed on
however white could simply go for
knight f3 and i believe or bishop e2
just try to develop
and i believe that was actually one of
the suggestions to just simply develop
that is a great idea you develop you get
your pieces out now black would probably
do something maybe bishop v6
bishop v2 now get your queen out take
this black still holds
a small advantage but white has great
fighting chances so there's nothing
wrong with this position for white but
when you play this knight e4 you give
your opponent way too many chances now
black can simply do bishop f5 and now um
to be fair white should have taken over
here
um i think that was what uh
would be the best choice for white and
now after take
take take take now question black
blackjama
what do you think black should do
you could pin that bishop i think rookie
8 is a
decent idea bishop taking b2 is
definitely possible
anything else is there any square that's
kind of winking at you
nom nom that is very interesting uh
that's
that's such a cool coincidence ah
knight b4 thank you um
so
yeah i think that's a good idea to try
and get this knight
up there that would be very beneficial
night before
and if rookie one you just give that
check and you just take this guy and you
eat that pawn
and this king is just very misplaced
this
all these are not developed so black
would have an easier end game
so let's go back and i believe that is
why white didn't do this
and it's kind of there is another thing
too
we think when i say we i mean my brother
and i
think that the fisher's name was too
scary for white
to try to like for white to once to eat
the second pawn in like the first ten
moves
so that's probably another reason that
whites never took over here
um so yeah i think that's that's another
thing to consider and i've definitely
had that myself i have used my name and
i have used my higher rating and higher
title
and many of the games that i have
actually shown some of them
over here and i bluffed my way out of
the worst position
or if i had really bad position and
well not really bad if my opponent had
considerable advantage and i couldn't
really
um think of a good fighting chance
i would just offer a draw if if possible
and i've had multiple opponents
accepting that
i've had that done to me i've had higher
rated opponents just offering me draw
when their position was
uh worse or they didn't have as good of
a fighting chance as they should have
so there's nothing wrong with using your
name
anyways um knight g3 bishop comes back
to e6 we want to keep
our bishop and keep pressure on the
position
um in the game white played knight e4
sorry and again white played knights f3
knight e4
probably would have been more
interesting just a little bit because if
knight e4
then well if you take it now the queens
got exchanged but
at the same time i completely understand
why
white wouldn't want to play knight e4
you know he just played knight
knight g3 why would you want to come
back
so wifi knight f3 question
what should black do
you could start thinking about
developing one thing that bothers you
if it bothers you is this idea so you
could potentially either
take it over here or move your whoops
not that
or move your queen somewhere i think
those are
two okay nice i see i do with queen c7
great yep let's go for clean c7
um pin bishop g4 hold on
bishop g4 my problem with bishop g4
is something with bishop e2 you just
kind of help your opponent develop and
the problem is you played one with
bishop f5
then you came back to e6 and if you go
again to g4
just i black still holds a small
advantage but
i don't want to move my bishop three
times in three moves
it just feels like i'm playing
anti-chess
so knight f3 queen c7
uh to be fair yes you could have taken
but
um take take take take you grab the pawn
back but
it's you might have an easier time
sacrificing the queen if there is
actually a queen on the board
if you know what i mean i don't want to
exchange the queens i want to sacrifice
it
especially because we're doing queen
sacrifice so
queen c7 in the game black simply sorry
white simply played queen b1
which is weird queen b1 just doesn't
really make any sense
either i think you should try to develop
either you should develop
and castle or you should
try to be a little more active so what
do you guys think why to move
how do you think white can be more
active
yes i am a big fan of red bull i usually
only drink it when i have exams
or need to stay awake but today i just
saw it
and i had to have it don't really have
any exams at the moment
but
last few days have been so stressful
just i had to
have an application submitted for
my school for a committee evaluation and
so much typing i did finish my medical
school personal statement though so
if anybody wants to read it
okay so i still have interesting ideas
with bishop d3 or rook d1
um think more active oh thank you 4 xl
yep f5 would have been the most
interesting line
after take now bishop d3 now white is
trying to activate his pieces as much as
possible
even though it would still black still
holds great advantage
white would have a better fighting
chance and now you can simply go
check us yes bishop d2 queen c5 stopping
your castle and i'm still trying to grab
this pawn
but it's at least white is at least
making
some effort to um
bother black and well
if white doesn't do anything we're gonna
see what happens to him
so white played queen b1 as black it's
time let's eat the pawn
and now white played f5 um
it's a little i think it's a little too
late
and after ef5 well
what do you think we should do as black
obviously we can't simply take it so do
you see any other move besides taking
how old was i when i learned chess well
that's a that's a very long story but i
was
six when i started actually playing
chess i knew that the moves before that
but it's a very very long story
any other ideas besides taking
nice nice similarly yep e4
and the idea of e4 is super great
because
to be fair you could simply
you could simply take over here and
after take now take take you have this
knight d6
you activate your knights you are pretty
much
dominating the center some e4 could come
up some f5 could come up there's so many
different things that black could do and
to enjoy this position
however um fisher kind of hates
hated traits so that's that kind of
explains why he does not
exactly love trading stuff
so um fisher played e4
and now white took on e6 do you think
taking on e6 is a good idea if
and well
if it if you don't think taking is a
good idea what do you think was the best
idea
and well obviously after take we are
going to take that
knight
yes queen e4 is the best move you're
correct
however yeah taking here is best
keep in mind if you take with knight
i'll just play bishop f5
so don't do that and if you were to play
queen takes c4 that's the best one now
we get to take over there
take over there and if you make the
mistake by taking back with the knight i
can simply
give you this check and pick up your
horsey
um and the best move is to play queen
into back to c2
bishop moves away and then you play
knight h5 and
white still has a good fighting chance
black still holds advantage but white
has
good fighting chance and when you're
playing fisher that's
probably as good as it's gonna get
anyways in the game white play take well
we take back
take and um now black team
what do you think we should do obviously
taking is just good enough but
what do you think is the best move
um yeah i i had a
really hard i usually have a really hard
time explaining to
um students or just the
beginners that the the difference of
sacrifice and blunder
and it's well to me it kind of makes
sense because sacrifice is something
noble that leads to the good of the rest
of the pieces
you get more chances it's i always
imagine like this
uh in like war like this night going to
sacrifice itself so
other people can take over the castle i
i like action movies
um i actually started watching so many
clips of game of thrones recently
but besides that um so
but blunder is like it's something
that's horrible you do what you lose
sacrifice is good you win or at least
your position gets better
so yeah i know everybody kind of jokes
about it but
it's it's just one of those language
things
um i don't think i've actually seen this
move
so far so i see some ideas with knight
d6 queen e5
queen a5 they're all possible
but
let's see anything else
these two are kind of winking at me i
really wish i had a pawn over here
and if anybody sees something
any magical pawns to grow thank you yes
let's go for f5
your idea is clear i want to fork you
so you have to stop it by a four and now
i have new squares that are winking at
me
how can i how can i use this
winking squares
any suggestions is there any specific
piece that's
not really working thank you guys knight
f6
we're activating our pieces and piece
activity
i can't emphasize how important piece
activity
is you should always activate your
pieces
as much as possible while making your
opponent feel miserable because they
can't activate their pieces because they
have to take so much time
just diffusing your threats
so now uh in the game white played
bishop e2 trying to develop trying to
stop knight g4
now black to move what do you think we
should do as black
you have a great position you can as
might as well try to enjoy your position
just a little bit and develop a few of
your
pieces
i say some really cool ideas
all right i see some nice rook moves
being suggested there's a rook d8
there's a
e8 okay cool let's go let's bring out
our rooks
to be fair this rook is not really doing
much
at its current position so let's develop
it
um so fischer is kind of enjoying this
game
and you are trying to double up your
rooks
try to make quite miserable on the e
file
and in the game i played king f2 i don't
exactly um like it
but at the same time there's not much
else that white can do even if you
castle i'll just eat over here
and um just bring up the other one
and it's like already plus seven for
black so
this is a quite a miserable position and
you're also losing a piece i forgot to
mention that part
so it's it's kind of a sad position
even if you move this out still even if
you play bishop f2 i'll still play
knight
d4 you take it i'll take with check
and also this guy's fine it's just a
very sad position
i thank you for your donation pt
so let's go back to the
original king of two now black to move
what do you think we should do
is that a black cat that's such a cute
cat
take pawn yeah let's go take pawn rookie
one
we dabble up bishop f3 and now
so black position is winning we are also
kind of as black we're kind of ready to
explode so you're kind of ready to start
sacrificing you start taking things
your position is much better and you all
you have to just finish it up
so how do you think you should finish it
up
so black to move to be honest
uh there are like so many different ways
to win
but let's think about the best one
knight g4 wins knight
d4 wins bishop f8 wins king hay twins
but which one is the best
thank you for excel yeah taking on e3 is
the best take take take
now what should black do
so black to move you are almost there
just a little bit longer until you win
this game
to be honest um not everybody
whoa sorry not everybody like to
sacrifice in a winning position so
there's nothing wrong with
playing a chill sometimes i play chill
um
so it's more of a personal choice and
kind of depends on how much you trust
yourself do you trust yourself enough to
be able to sacrifice in a winning
position
or do you want to play it safe
for excel do you know this game
so any cool checkmate threads again to
be fair
most of the moves win this but the best
one
is some cool check
keep in mind that these squares are
occupied
these squares are occupied this score is
occupied with the knight
and this diagonal could be occupied with
the bishop
so anybody wanna get this king to come a
little bit
higher so we can do a bishop h6 and
shake his hand
thank you yes queen takes f4 amazing
if you take kaboom amazing meat um
if you don't take well you just lost a
pawn and well
the longest one is maintain 13 moves
king f2
knight g4 king g2
another check king f2
uh i can't even do like knight d4
it's just it's just super made like you
can't get away with this
yeah um so this is a super mate
with queen f4 and this was a very
brilliant way to end this game
um white can't take it because we get
checkmate
if you move the king away fisher is
gonna
march with all the pieces knights
bishops
and um so opponent actually resigned and
didn't give fisher
the pleasure of giving him meat with
bishop which i wish he did
it was a really great masterpiece by
fisher
and he really did punish his opponent
for
delaying castle to grab pawns now we're
gonna go
and look at one of fears just games
surprisingly he lost this one
i usually show his great games this was
a very great and beautiful game just
for his opponent so
um no it was the best move pd
yeah i wish i could see sacrifices
easier too
i see them but sometimes i personally
prefer to
take the more safer rule root route
route yes
root is a name it's a person so let's
take a look
at this cool game
same ish ideas with king indian
a little different because ali reza
plays played h3
compared to well to be fair fisher
castled first so
but still castle bishop c5 there are
simply
theory and here white played knight d2
well the idea is that white wants to
bring knight b3
but um well how do you think black
should continue
if any of you do know the opening feel
free to
talk about it if you don't know the
opening just try to come up with
what makes most sense
ah my new tea
it's not as amazing as i was hoping it
would be but
um
queen before um not exactly
yeah you should take on d4 yep and
after knight b3 so
this was such a weird game and i
know alireza and i know murali because
he was always in like world youths and
asian youths and i've seen
him around and i kind of remember eliza
from how
when he was like die high so um
it's very interesting to me to see this
game because i know
these two boys when they were yay high
and
right now i think they're both way
taller than me
and higher rated than me but um
so now what do you think we should do
yes to be fair
queen e5 is the simplest way to go queen
c7 is another way queen b6 is another
way
but what do you think about take
does it scare you do you think it's
crazy
it's more it's if kind of more feels
like a deer
from morality to sacrifice queen on move
four
that's crazy i agree it's crazy to me
too
well you have to take back because if
you don't take back you just lost a
piece
i'll say i'll take your second piece and
in the game white played f3 what do we
think about f3 do you think already
f3 is good bad
nice well bad because he lost that kind
of makes sense
um but well it's not exactly bad it's
just
the problem is that it's kind of hard to
find a move
um the problem is the pawn structure
because if you take it
these is i think the funniest fun
structures
that i've seen in a while um the problem
with this bond structure
is that now you can easily just
like take this guy now c3 is also
falling
yes you can play rook to c1 but again
there is bishop e5 and this is another
hole to be poked
so i um i would not recommend that
uh if you play something like bishop d3
to keep your pawns that's more
recommended that's the best way to go
but you still take
and again knight comes to c6 and it's
very unclear position
but the problem is that well the good
news is that at least for white he
doesn't have to keep worrying about
having that monstrous e3 pawn and
it's still a great fight but well white
has a queen and next to um
in exchange for two pieces so
not the most horrifying
position so what do you think black
should do after f3
also also all these weeks of black
squares these dark squares are just
really winking at me
i don't think no we should not take that
it's good to sacrifice but
if you keep sacrificing you ain't going
to be having any pieces
i kind of like the idea of just knight
c6 i think that's doable but knight dash
5 makes the most sense
trying to already poke these squares
also poke that pawn a lot of poking uh
in the game white played queen c1
defending your bishop attacking
defending that pawn attacking this bomb
um
do you think this pawn is worth
defending because if it is you got to
defend it
if it's not worth defending then you can
just develop and let it fall
do you think it's worth defending
okay i see some yeses okay good so let's
go defend it
and the game uh others have played g4
which was not
it's it's an interesting idea but i
think it might have just been easier to
just like develop
and um to just try to get more pieces
here
uh something like e2 i don't i'm not
really worried about that that's not
really something to consider
it doesn't really make sense um
something like knight d7 to try and go
to e5 or c5 could be interesting
and also maybe knight g3 a lot of things
coming up but i think knight d4 might
have been the best idea
g4 you just get knight f4 knight g3
is also possible but knight f4
is the better one because
we don't exactly want to exchange these
two together so when you play knight f4
you are kind of still threatening a lot
of things with e2 as well
now what do you think white should do e2
is coming up
or knight c6 is coming up or
anything else well a lot of things are
coming up but
let's say white just does something
weird now e2
and black is winning because if you take
i have that
nasty chick i'll pick up your queen if
you don't take your bishop is falling so
[Music]
white should do something a little more
exciting
okay i see the ideas with there should
be two to stop
that is perfectly doable
the ideas of moving the queen okay queen
c2 or b2 or d1 or b1
uh-huh
i don't think you can you should take it
because knight g2
again i'll pick up your queen
so yeah in the game white played king d1
that is
a little out of the harmony because
your king is kind of getting out of this
chicks but at the same time
well i'm just going to relocate my
knight to e6
now i could go after that pawn i could
go after
c5 i could just start pushing the spot
there's so many different possibilities
so that is not exactly the perfect idea
um so here after knight e6
king went to c2
trying to run away develop now i want to
play g5
to block my bishop what do you think we
should do
well the check was not good enough
because bishop would simply take it
if you took knight takes bishop then
queen would take on h6
after king d1 yeah exactly bishop f4
keep your bishop uh in the game white
played queen d1
now black to move what do you think we
should do
you have a cool position you have enough
compensation
you are on the cost
casp of having a nice advantage
so what do you think we should do
well i don't think we should start
opening the position this is a very
positional game
so we shouldn't just try to open up the
center we should still try to develop we
should still try to
form attack but mainly with our
with our knights and with our bishops
the seo file is also open we could
uh dig something like that okay i see
some ideas with bishop e5
sorry knight e5
that's doable um something like a5 is
also worth considering because then you
would want to
move this as well
all right yeah let's go knight e5 it is
uh
in the game white played knight c1 i'm
assuming
first he was very confused second he
really hated this idea of uh having to
deal with this pawn
and the squares were super weak so i see
one kind of makes sense
but uh something like h5 makes it a
little bit more sense but the problem
with h5 is that
to be fair i can just play g5 and this
this side is completely
blocked so that's that
what do you think we should do after c
and knight c1
again to be fair instead of knight c1
rook c1 and then king b1 to have like a
fake castle
was best choice for white
keep in mind next why white wants to try
and trade some of these powerful pieces
so if we just play something like a5
he is going to just bring up the knight
and try to
get rid of some of our cool pieces
especially this awesome bishop
i see some ideas so let's let's think
about it differently all these pieces
are working so let them be
is this bishop working are these rooks
working maybe we could
get them out okay i see the crowd is
warming up to this idea
nice also also you are plotting some
cool checks
it's kind of peaceful looking but it's
another knife
so now
what if pawn goes to a4
how are you doing
see everybody is doing good okay so
i like the idea of getting my pieces out
so let's go let's get the work out
uh in the game white played knight e2
which is not the best
idea knight d3 would be the best idea
now let's talk about this knight d3 a
little bit
what do you think we should do as black
we have few options we can take over
here we could take over there
or we could move this bishop away
i think those are our best three choices
i don't think we should move this bishop
because g5 exists
or simply you could also
lose a piece but just the
the existence of g5 should be reason
enough for you to not play bishop h6
so bishop takes this out now should we
take the pawn or
the knight
to be fair taking on c4 does not work
because
take take and queen e1 and you lose this
pawn
because well bishop c4 is coming up and
then
bye bye so this is a very very strong
pawn we should not be losing it
um so in the game black simply
realized the importance of this bishop
and he took whoops and he
took this oh my god i am so sorry in the
game
knight d3 was not played knight d3 would
have been the best try
and if that happened uh if black
is a smart and realizes the importance
of this bishop there we go my grammar is
correct now
black should take over here if take now
knight c5 attacking this bishop
keeping my pawn safe and going after a4
kaboom and still getting your pieces all
coordinated
this is still kind of better for black
but
um white does have
some the better chances compares to any
other line that we've seen so far
so all right
in the game uh alireza played knight e2
i think he had the same idea but a
little um
a little different method now what do
you think black should do
i think we should still save this bishop
so bishop h6 is
our first choice second choice can we
take it over here but that would be
exact same as the line we just
take take and just queen e1 and taking
over here losing this pawn so i don't
think we should go for that one
so knight c4 is out bishop h6 seems to
be my main choice
now do we see anything else to
keep this bishop on the board
because this is a very important bishop
oh thank you yutgu
that is a good point brent we should try
to keep the position closed
uh it's time we should bring this this
bishop back
g5 we bring our bishop back
and in the game i also played bishop h3
best move trying to cook something up
over here
now we have two pawns to eat which one
do you think we should take
with as black and again black
does have a great
advantage
well that's when we have sacrificed our
queen
uh in this super strategic way we
shouldn't open the position up because
if you open the position up
his queen will show his strength and i
don't want that strong queen
all right i see you're pretty divided
between taking f3 or c4
i'm loving that knight takes f3 i think
it's a little bit better
taking on c4 uh with rook is also
possible
going after this guy i don't think there
is that much difference between it
feel free to correct me but um
they could be take take on f4 and i feel
a little uncomfortable with that but
then again there's knight g4 and
s i don't think there's a such huge
danger i just felt more comfortable
taking this pawn right in front of me
c4 is gonna be here later too
queen d3 see here's come back and
now you get to eat that c4 pawn we lost
our e3 pawn but that pawn
um was not as stable as
we would hope so when the bishop was
kicked back to g7
so now queen goes to after because we're
attacking the queen now black to move
what do you think we should do
um having the knight on c4 was nice
but it would still give white some ideas
to try and push this pawn
so it was it has it's like a trade-off
which one would you want to which
position do you think is
less uh hopeful for your opponent
yep taking on f3 was the best one all
right i think
i see an idea of trying to maybe going
for c3
i don't really want to play knight e5
just yet i kind of like my knight over
here
no i don't think we should i mean f5 is
still doable but
you shouldn't do moves that helps your
opponent
this pawn here helps you more than being
on f5
the king is over here let's go attack
that guy so how about something like
getting your rooks doubled up for
example
rook c5 now if your opponent plays like
rook b1
now you can just go bishop c6 you're
going after
the bishop taking on e4
bishop g2 and now
i think you guys are gonna like this
move
black to move what do you think we
should do
this is a move that was recently
mentioned then i kind of said no to it
oh also that's kind of cool there's more
than 200 of you watching live
huh thank you
let's go for 300.
no well it's a little different
situation
our rook is activated our bishop is more
activated than when it was on d7
and now it's time to go with kaboom
f5 is good uh i like it that
i think something like a5 was also
interesting but f5 makes the most sense
it's time to get this stroke
active uh take over here bishop can take
rook f1 and in the game
um it's kind of weird because i
it seems like alireza is trying to give
his queen back
uh by allowing some sort of discovery
with this bishop
because uh
the best one would be to play like queen
g3 to try and keep the queen
and then you would play like rick h5 go
after this pawn
and then knight c5 and you see how
active these pieces are it's
it should it must have been very
miserable poor kid
yeah and then also this pawn is falling
a little upon
the falling here a little pawn falling
there i wouldn't want to be white and i
say that
and you guys know i'm very materialistic
and i love my queens
anyways rook f1 bishop took c3 queen c5
take take take take and
now we're at this position who do you
think is better
i think this would be kind of a great
transition before we start our end-game
puzzles too let me actually
checking with the producer
you want to do two hours instead of just
splitting it
i like the number of viewers i don't
want them to go away
we can extend it yeah just have this go
into the second hour yeah it's already
nice end game right here
all right we got it producer so guys
don't go anywhere
we had a plan to kind of cut it and
restart for the end game but i kind of
like the numbers
let's keep going i can do this i have my
t
cold but still t alright so i see that
black is better and you all kind of
agree with it
so anybody wants to tell me a move
yeah wait did it get an extension
oh thank you guys
oh all right so i see some nice ideas
with moving knight e3 or knight e5
do we have a preference
knight e3 or knight to e5
okay i see knight e5 is the choice
and i love it let's go so you have these
three pieces
um for those two
oops and a rook and you also have a
bunch of pawns
so you basically have a knight and three
pawns in exchange for a rook
that is usually a good challenge for
white
for the side that has rook but in this
position you also have
so many weak pawns so that should be
easy win for black
so white played a5 you're also dropping
another pawn
i think taking on with bishop would
be even a little bit better thank you
roger that's very sweet of you
taking with bishop would even be better
but
the problem is that well simply well
sorry not the problem
uh the the problem for white is that
after take
take the knight can just come back to c5
and then again there is another pokey
pokey another pokey pokey
yeah it's kind of painful and i kind of
want a pokeball right now
anyways so white uh
after knight takes e4 white has to take
back and now
the dynamic is just slightly changed
uh because it's a bishop versus rook
but there is four pounds four pawns now
so we we can easily feel that
black has the upper hand but
um what do you how do you want to show
your skills so i think we're officially
starting our end game class too
i kind of like having a little
transition
uh just fyi if if there's any you're
more than welcome to
uh watch the game as i'm showing it on
leaches but if you do
and you see the moves uh feel free to
throw hints but don't tell them move
i still want to be able to chat with the
chat
uh-oh i
um asdf i
don't know how i feel about that i kind
of like that it's a little weird
but well in my language that actually
means shiny and bright and all those
cute feelings
my last name yeah
that nobody can pronounce in us
um so here what do you think we should
do well
first things first we should get this
king up we should we should most likely
have this
bishop somewhere to protect some of
these squares that the knight can
poke into uh we should try to get a pass
pawn so that's kind of our general idea
um i think something like
uh maybe bishop d5 is the best way to go
actually so
sorry and bishop d5 is actually
something that happened but
something like bishop d3 was also just
as interesting king f5 was again just as
playable
bishop d5 kind of just holds this
position no more knight jumping
knight went to b5 and i'm going out well
what's going after my pawn
i have no plans on giving you that pawn
bishop holding the knights in his place
checking up
checking up uh careful not to do fun
stuff and get checkmated
oof no no no funny business not today
king h6 rook f8 now
what do you think black should do
there's not much that white can do to
keep her his pawns safe
but white is doing its best so how do
you think black can
continue with that
okay i see you guys are doing super well
yes
king s5 is the best way let's go eat
some ponds orchids eight
you shouldn't give up your pawn keep the
pawn ponds are delicious let's keep them
you shouldn't lose this pawn because if
you simply took over here that will not
be good because you lose this pawn
and then you lose this pawn and now it's
kind of a equal position white has
just good enough position to fight for a
draw
and you should not give up pieces no
pieces no pawns
and specifically in the positions where
it doesn't require it
don't do it don't give up free stuff so
h6 uh white played rook h7
let's eat that now when you eat age six
you're not eating my e7 as well
because now if you were to try to play
something like rook h7
now i can just go over here you can't
you shouldn't really take that as big as
now king f6 and your knight or your rook
fall
so don't do that um
knight d4 now how should we play the
trick here is that
you as black should play it safe but at
the same time you should play it
interesting you should you shouldn't let
your opponent have
too much fun uh you shouldn't let white
try to
take away your pawns or pieces but at
the same time you should play safe
and at the same time you should push the
pawn there we go you should get a pass
pawn and don't let your pawns fall
i like that don't do don't give up your
pawns
so what do you think you should do here
as
black do you think we're done with this
bishop did it or do you think like do
you think it's worth it should we start
pushing pawns should we
try to attack this rook i see the idea
of bishop e4
i think bishop before the problem with
it is that
remember here we just talked about why
r7 didn't work because king would come
to a5 attack this and then go to f6 and
defend the pawn
but if you wait too long if you play
like bishop before there is rook h7
and you should not lose this pawn
because you lose this pawn the next
thing you know d6 is falling next thing
you know
b7 is being on heavily attacked so you
shouldn't do that
so
after knight d4 how can we come up with
an idea to keep this pawn
safe
i see a lot of king f5s i think you guys
mentioned g5
if you mean that you're correct again
doing something like g5 is doable bishop
f5 is doable not the best idea but
doable
king g5 is the best one if you were to
play like rook h7
i could just play king a6 keep my
bishops keep my pond safe
if you decide to take it i'm just going
to take that back with the knight and
i'm going to eat your other
one last pawn so let's go
in the game white simply played drinkage
too now
should we save this bishop or should we
let it go
i kind of like working with two laptops
it's a little easier
i get to read the chat i get to see the
full screen
so i see a lot of what it goes
but are you sure if we let it go
we we don't exactly have to take it with
the um we don't exactly have to take it
back
with the knight because this rook can
simply go to a2 and defend it
i think this might be a good time to
keep it let's keep the bishop
yeah let's save the bishop let's go
bishop d5 i like keeping my bishops a
good bishop
now in the game um eliza played rookie 2
as you can probably imagine this is a
pretty hopeless game
but it's still you should still fight it
even if it's a hopeless game
hopeless games are still worth fighting
and
so for that reason i think
it's good that arizona is fighting i
don't think it's i don't think you
should resign just because the position
is worse
and yes i know it's really bad but all
right so
let's start pushing this pawn let's get
the king up
king defend it i don't want to lose this
pawn
so let's keep it attack the knight and
now
let's keep my center super activated
again to be fair g5 here is just good
enough
you are just going to make a queen
nothing wrong with that
but bishop e4 makes more makes it more
miserable for whites and when i say
miserable
i sincerely do mean miserable because
just look at this
white can't attack anything white can't
push anything
a white can't develop anything this king
is just
miserable cut off from the world can't
really go anywhere
this rook is just looking super sad this
knight can't really attack anything it's
such a sad position
for white i felt poor for i felt so bad
for poor eliza anyways
knight e3 now knight and king are here
what do we want to do where should we
poke as black
any suggestions d5 i like it
let's go we want to poke over here king
b4
and what do you think we should do now
very close very close to winning
few more poke pokeys oh sorry
i keep scrolling down by accident
anybody
again to be fair i can't think of a move
that does not win
well actually if you don't as long as
you don't give anything up for free
i can't think of a move that doesn't win
um but knight d4
is the most um painful one i want to say
knight g1 is another one d4 is just as
good
but just to avoid checks just to make
white
extremely hopeless just go knight d4
attack the rook
rookie one just king f3 your knight is
just
completely tied up next this
pawn is just ready to promote
you can't really move your rook because
you lose the knight
if you play something if you can't you
can't even move your knight because you
get forked
and to be fun to make it even a little
bit more fun
if you play king c5 king f2 and you lose
this knight anyways
so this is a super masterpiece by murali
good job it was a very great game
sorry alright this is a masterpiece that
you were the victim of
but i really enjoyed it i hope you guys
did too
now let's go ahead and use the tag the
the talents that we've gained in
some puzzles
why to yes why to move
i apologize no leeches
why are you showing this bad leeches
this was the position bad leeches
ah man at least someone's having fun
anyways i guess my first puzzle was
sacrificed
um it was a good puzzle so
i'll give it a small try if you were one
of the few
who was just looking at his phone and
didn't see the
answer to this puzzle why to move what
do you think we should do
i'll give it maybe just 30 seconds i
don't want to spend so much time on it
especially because um leeches kind of
got a little too funny i like this
puzzle
yeah maybe for our next one ben we can
give it like a second
for me to make sure that leeches is not
messing with me
yeah i feel like a beautiful flower or
something
or snow i miss though
so the idea is that either either of
these two moves work
so the idea is that you just kind of
want to get this king
under a check so knight d5 is the way to
go it's very interesting because
keep in mind if you played bishop b1
with id a bunch of checks
the problem is queen goes to a8
and um now you're kind of getting
checkmated
so the move that you do should include
this knight coming into this diagonal
and now if you were to take it now i can
do wish obi-wan and now i want to give
you the check and go eat your queen
and there's nothing you can do as black
knight e4 does win as well if you play
queen a8
knight g5 king h4 i can take this
and this is still winning but it's not
as winning as
uh it would be for um
knight d5 so let's just stick with the
super winning one
all right i hope lisa is not messing
with me otherwise i'm gonna have some
beef with it
all right let me check the next puzzle
why is it doing this why it gives why
does it keep showing the final position
i know but i'm a little i'm a little
unhappy with this give me a second to
check every single puzzle is showing me
the last move oh my god we might have to
keep switching for every puzzle
ah man anyways okay
so right now this this is good i can
show this
why to move what should we do
you have two bishop versus one bishop
can you win this
to be fair you can't win this because it
says it right under here
but how
it is white to move just to confirm i am
puzzle too it's a good puzzle
i'll give you guys maybe 30 seconds and
then i'll look at the chats because i do
want to give you the chance to actually
enjoy the beauty of this puzzle you
should definitely think about checks
but you should also be aware of if you
give check can go switch seven and i
kind of want to run away so you
shouldn't
let the king run away that should be
your
um kind of main idea
not to let the king run
king g3 where are you
okay so i see a lot of bishop c2s even
though bishop c2 yes does work and yes
king g6 works
um that is not the exact way of doing it
um the best one is actually
let me see do i see this move not yet
not yet okay i see
one or two people having mentioned that
this move
oh my god this is a good puzzle
i'll tell you i'll give you one more
hint it is made
in four moves
and it's not bishop c2 bishop c2 is like
mate in
12 14.
so latent four the first one to give me
the line
will be named as the king of bishops
i've been watching the little clips of
game of thrones
uh so far i only know i only saw i only
see single moves
anybody trying for a
uh brands bishop c2 does work it's just
not
made in it's not just
uh it's not a short it's not
as efficient of a mate there we go if
that makes sense
okay i see the idea um so let's look at
a line i like i see that king f8
bishop g8 and bishop b2 is being
suggested i
love it now question what if king f8
king goes to h7
then what do we do
also let me see who was it who was the
idea
shannon you were the king of bishops
because i think you were the first one
to say the line
or the idea there we go
yes if king of eight king goes to h7
bishop c2 and when you move kaboom
and if you defend it i'll just take it
and that's just
way too pleasant all right
ben you ready for a little switch
there we go hold on let me see ah this
is
so weird leeches is really messing with
me all right this position is ready
let's go you guys just have some fun
with this one
um why to move what should we do
this shouldn't be too hard it's just
more of a
fun puzzle but at the same time
if black plays it's wrong you can easily
win it
so good luck
that's that kind of that's the question
should we push to make queen or not
because if you push to make queen there
is this nasty rookie too
queen a1 check take its steel mate
because g2 king g1 and no king g3 for
you
so should we make a queen
are you happy with just a draw
so if you shouldn't make a queen then
yes you should make a rook
but again that brings up the question
when you make a rook
does that help you win let's say uh
let's say you make a rook
let's say rook goes to b2 then what do
you do
again it wants to give you check or
give you um
yes it still wants to give you checks so
if you make a queen it will still
try to play that idea with check
and check
we should make another rook that is true
if you make a queen
it will still give you check whoops
sorry my bad
check ah we should make a rook but if
you make a queen
i want to make a queen let me make a
queen there we go check
check and now it's the still mate again
because
when you push give a check your queen is
again
protecting this square so you should
make a rook
again oh my goodness there's a lot of
rooks
so now this is winning for white uh to
be
fair here black would have given check
given uh gone
here to threaten checkmate when you come
down here
could have gone there and could have
thrown in bunch of checks
if you go to e1 goes to b2 to stop you
and want to make g2
um so here it's black did have the idea
to hold the draw however this was
not exactly the
ideal position because imagine this
position black has a full rook
in exchange for two pawns also mate
threat also
pawn so i don't think making a draw was
the first thing
on um
your mind so good
um all right so why does it matter to
not make a queen because
whenever you made a queen it would be
the looking at this g3 square and it
would be a stillmate
okay ready for next one
again bad leeches all right i'm ready
why to move how should we whoop black
and to be fair i think everybody can
agree that
white is the one pushing for a win and
i'll give you
a little um
i'll give you a little hint it's made in
nine moves you don't have to find all
the nine moves you can find the start of
it
put this tea away too it's way too cold
at this point
uh these are mine yes well actually
these are
i have the i have a humongous collection
so yes they are mine
but uh they're also alicia's at the end
of today
i do plan to share them uh i do want to
share the link
all right i see some ideas with knight
d6
some ideas with um king f6
i'm not gonna offer a draw uh-uh i told
you slate nine moves
all right king f7 is good you guys are
correct
uh but let's say after king f7 what if
black plays um roxy one then what do you
do
this is made in five moves anybody want
to give it a try
i'll title you the king of three pieces
bishop e7 there you go hey
shannon you can't have all the titles
you're kind of yeah you're kind of
winning by wasting your time bishop e7
and the idea is that this trick is
super stuck if you go to g1 i'll just
give you check
and you can't really do that because
kaboom mates
so let's say no rook c1 let's say king
goes to h7
then how do we win
king of 7 was brilliant we also take a
lot of squares away from the king
what else
don't really have any checks well we
have checks but
it's not exactly the way to go
mehmed i think you are correct
bishop of fate you cut the king's eye uh
king's route um knight g5 is
actually the fastest way to win king
ishait and then bishop f8
um because now you're just threatening
mating
well one but you could start bishop of
faith
just as well and you still want to give
this check to be fair now he can take
this
but that doesn't really help this is
already a checkmate
almost and this king is already in the
correct corner for us
we just have to take a bishop e7 not let
the king run
king h5 knight e3 don't let the king run
it's very important no running kings
king moves away um
knight goes away king comes king comes
king h6
now let's do knight f4 we just got to
get this king
a little pushed away king goes there i
don't want you to go there so let's
block that
king g8 let's go king f6 snow king up
for you
king h7 i don't want you to do that
king g8 bishop
no let's go with knight t6 bishop g7
wins two but nice e6
king move king move there chekito
and kaboom all right
um the trick with doing a
knight and bishop checkmate is if you
have a dark squared bishop
the king needs to be in one of those
corners
if if if you start from center
um the king will refuse to go to this
good center good corner for you so the
easier way is to push it to the
wrong corner and then maneuver with your
bishop at night and like
little by little push it to the other
corner
all right i am ready to go to the next
one
yeah bad leeches all right
um hold on let me no no it doesn't work
nope we're good uh white to move
it is kind of like triangles yeah
don't you move that king i mean
eventually i will because i wanted to
give you checkmate but
if you're going to get the knight to g3
that's checkmate if you can get the
knight to f2 with king
wing on f1 that's checkmate how many
moves
well you tell me can you get checkmate
i'll give you guys 30 seconds before i
tell you yes or no on checkmates
okay i see a lot of yeses yes you can
have checkmate and it is checkmate in
four moves
but you only have one move that will
lead to
checkmate what do you think that move is
it is not knight d3
you have a single move that will go
to become a cool checkmate
well that's not true pt i've shown a lot
of puzzles that
were only draws and it's disappointed a
lot of people
so
right i'll give you another clue it is
made in four moves
and i will not share anything more until
somebody tells me the line
you guys can collaborate you can ask
each other question
i think i could give you another mini
clue too
if your knight was on e3 you would have
an easier time trying to win
so you should get that knight trying to
go to e3
however knights you have to kind of
decide
is it knight c4 or knight g4
so you are at that position
so what is the difference between knight
g4 or knight c4
because one of them wins one of them
doesn't so if you can try and understand
the difference between them that should
also
help you
so i see a lot of you finding the cool
maneuver
but
the problem with king f1 is bishop b5
check
king f2 and then bishop goes to e2
if you take king jito wants to make a
queen
that got to be painful
um
all right so i see that you guys are
doing a great job the problem with
knight c4 is this
bishop g6 now your knight is kind of cut
off if you go
knight e3 then bishop just goes to d3
stops both of your f5 and f um
ones and even if you go knight to g4 now
again bishop f5
if you go knight type 6 trying to go to
h5
bishop g6 it kind of keeps on keeping
tap on your bit knight and that's not
going to
do it so that's why you should go knight
to g4
and your idea is if bishop goes to g6
now you don't have to go to e3
you can't play knight to f6 and now
black is in zugswang
because now if you doesn't matter where
you move your bishop you're going to
lose control of one of these two squares
and that square is critical to getting
to g3
that's why it's such a cool puzzle and
the other thing with knight g4
is even even i mean if you do something
as chill as bishop f7 i'll just go
knight e3
and i want to go both of these squares
and you can't stop them both
so yeah any question for this puzzle
all right i'm gonna flip it
all right ready to go
why to move how are you gonna
um
survive this
of yep
i think so
they're way too cool to be actual games
i mean black is threatening to make a
queen so if you can't get a draw
you should probably be popping
champagnes if you're
over 21 years old or if you're in europe
and over 18.
shannon you are pretty strong yeah good
that is kind of the idea now
which one should we start with first
bishop g4 or h3
uh eduardo yes please
well that's the cute thing if you play
bishop g4 it doesn't exactly
lose the bishop because you can't really
take because i'll give you a check
and i'll come eat this pawn
so that's good you want that
right so i'm hoping you want that
so the the good thing is the
let me rephrase that the issue is if you
played h3 first
now there is this nasty g4 if you take
with bishop it makes it queen
and the king is free to move around and
poke you
left and right so that's why you
shouldn't play h3 first and you should
play this bishop g4 first
and after bishop g4 black can simply
well black makes a queen and now we do
h3
keep in mind to not play f3 can you tell
me why f3
is a bad move
there are multiple ways for white to um
for black to win this but if you could
just tell me
which one is the easiest one or the most
efficient one that'll do two
uh queen g3 i'll take your i would love
it if you play queen g3 i'll take you
give you check mainta
shannon finally i got one
well you didn't get one yes i'm kidding
i'm rooting for you to get one
but to get all of them but um no queen
d2
then when you move the king now queen e2
kind of putting you in a little pickle
because now if you don't really have
king h1
you can't really move this bishop
because you lose this pawn
you can't really push this pawn because
king goes to g3
so just a tiny bit of zugs long
if you want king f1 i would also eat
over here and then my king is free
ha yes finally all right um
ready for next one
i'm still quite disappointed in leeches
all right how do we feel about this one
i feel weird actually
huh
so try your best to find the draw
ah this is a very rough position so i
would strongly recommend you guys to
take your time
think about it who's some of it's white
to move uh usually
if a puzzle is not wise to move i will
be sure to tell you
but if i don't flip the board it is
generally white to move
you're doing a good job thinking about
the checks but
the problem is if queen takes f5 bishop
goes to c2
and if you move your queen
well let me show you why queen f5
doesn't work
then we can probably try and figure out
the best move
if you play queen f5 bishop f2
sorry bishop c2 and uh well depending on
where you go with your queen let's see
where was the suggestion let's say we go
back to e5
um check king a4
bishop moves and wants to give you
checkmate
z if you take it
actually i can do this too check king b5
check can be four check
and mate
or b5 bishop mate yay
yes so um this
your king is extremely unsafe here on b5
so you can't just sac you can't just
um eat ponds and yes there was a nice
idea about sacrifice everything and
get still made how do you want to
sacrifice everything
okay rick d6 yes 66 is the best move
um if bishop takes d6 check
get rid of queen still mate if queen
goes to c2
you can get rid of your rook this way
and take that and still going on
um this is a still drawable
you're not super losing as white anymore
you're not getting checkmated
if check i can take that sorry sorry i
can play king a4
now when you take that i just get rid of
my queen and again
still meet if you go bishop a4
what about that because keep in mind if
we take it
he's just going to take our rook
should he take it or should we go king
c4 what do you think do we still have a
still mate with king c4
yep good job and if you keep checking
i can easily just go back um
if you take that all i have to do is get
rid of my queen
you take that all i have to do is get
rid of my queen
and okay um what about to move after
rook d6
queen d6 we can get rid of this what
about the move queen c1
how can we what do you think about this
i was thinking maybe take if king up
what about drug d2
that's if he takes this uh it's not
really a stillness oops
queen b1 the kink there's this
unfortunate f5 so we can't take that if
we take that
no more still so what else
well to be fair yes you do have to play
rook d1 good job
uh bishop d1 and now you actually have
to take king takes b4 and this is a this
is a
better position for black but you still
have some fighting chances
the problem is this check and
if you can get to these pawns in time
you still have a nice draw
but that's a little sketchy
taking over here going there this is
still a little sketchy but
it gives you a better fighting chance
compared to
your initial position when you are
getting super mated
all right ready for next one
any questions on this one or should i
move on
uh bret the brands yeah doesn't work
okay i am ready to flip
you ready for the next one oh yeah
this should be fun all right let's go
why to move
can we survive this
how do we feel about this one
it's good because you can't really move
your king
so the idea of knight e2 is
interesting the other idea that we could
consider
is um
no knight g2 is not it knight j2 just
king goes to g1
if you go knight e3 just records to h5
and defends this pawn
so not no tonight g2
i am a i'm kind of fond of knight e2
but anything else
all right i kind of like the idea of
knight h5 because if you take it
i have f4 and that's a steel mate yes
that is correct
um the problem with knight h5 is what if
you don't take and you play king g1
now if i play f3 again if you take it i
still have a 4
if you play king f2 now if i do f4
it's a little um king e3 now you take
over here
now it's still doable this is still kind
of holdable
for sorry not anymore um
it is kind of holdable for white but
it's not as pleasant however this is
again doable
what about f4 do you see any issues with
f4
ah my brother is here
chattoribona
well this is not a stimulate anymore as
long as black finds the best move
one move for black to win this game
yes nice rook to g6
now if you were to take over here now
king takes h2 and you're getting whooped
and you also have to lose your knights
to not get mated
what about so let's go back to the
original position
so we saw that knight h5 is very tricky
quite doable but the problem with knight
h5
is the idea with simply changing one
and if you push f3 the king kind of
chases your
uh your pawn if you wear oops if you
were to
play f4 then this cool rook g6
so let's look at knight e2 a little bit
deeper
what do we think about knight e2
let me ask you what if rook goes to h8
ideally we want to be able to take over
here but
we can't exactly force this rook out of
this set
out of defending this pawn so
yeah f4 is the best one
the problem is if you were to play
knight d4 now he has f4
and if you were to play like knight c2
now he has f3
and then like her goes to f8 and if you
take
now there's rook f4 just as well as
taking over here and it's just not
working
so that's why
f4 should be played and after f4
now um if you play something like let's
say
rook e8 now i can go knight d4 and i'm
eating your pawns and now white can't
hold the draw
so the best move is to go knight e2
however knight h5 is also tricky enough
that it gives you very good fighting
chances
and not i highly doubt that after knight
h5
your opponent is that strong to be able
to find king g1
and then like do this chase but then
again
let's let's not um think like that and
try our best to find the best moves any
question
oh a question about knight e2 rookie six
so if you run it t2 root goes to e6 you
can easily go knight d4 and start poking
pawns
if rook e4 now i can just take over here
rook f4 and i can just take that and
that's a draw
and e5 now i can just play f4 poke your
rook
i guess this those two yeah
then i just want to eat that pawn and
then go after this guy
all right i think you we're good
all right ready for flip
flip flip flip ooh this is a cool one
too
good luck with this one guys i'm just
gonna lay back
chill stretch maybe a little
sleep on the red bull
so i'll i'll give you a small hint that
is why to move that's not a very
small hint but the small hint is that
you have only one move
to hold the position
and you do have a very good
chance of finding it just make sure you
um
may i don't know what is the rating of
this puzzle um
i do know that if you think about what
does your opponent want and you find the
most efficient way of
blocking that you will find a move yep
eric your
opponent does want to take queen takes
e5 so you should
defend that
thank you brother
yep um and shannon
yes knight e6 is the best one
uh knight b3 doesn't exactly work
because it's too
slow and now you have this queenish
eight
if d4 there's queen h3 and you get poked
and you get poked this actually reminds
me of
i started playing the chess variants
horde
i can't win on it i've never one with it
when i have that
ginormous load of pawns but this kind of
reminds me of that
if you're if black can break through and
start eating and start poking on your
back ranks you are
dead but if here you can find a way to
keep
this queen on a leash you're perfectly
fine so
knight to e6 take d4
if coin goes to f3 it's already a
stillmate
that's kind of the fun of it and
he can't really break through and if he
doesn't do queen f3 right now
next movie you're doing king g2 so if he
goes like queen of shades so you want to
come in
now boom up here um
and then if queen just moves boom king g
bishop g1 and i'm just gonna like just
move with this bishop
back and forth and back and forth and
just kind of laugh at you
not out loud because i think i can't do
that in real tournaments over the board
but yeah the question is why not pawn
the problem is if you push spawn i can
easily take over here
and i'll eat that with check
and i can also give you maybe another
check or two
remove this guy another check or two
another check or two and i'll stop this
so this is not the ideal way to go
so yeah you want to keep everything
blocked
oh it's morning where you're well all
right let's try to squeeze in one more
let's end it with a win we looked at
bunch of draws now hold on hold on
this is kind of an easy theoretical
endgame
you guys should be able to do this i
trust in you
this is a win for white just tell me how
try to use your end game knowledge
what do we want to do in end games keep
the king cut
activate our own king push pawns right
that's kind of that should
summarize our end game ideas
king opposition is a very important one
to know
to be fair there is not only one way to
win this
because the rook a5 actually does work
yeah
rook g5 works pretty much anything on
the fifth rank works but except the ones
that you give it for free
because the cool thing is that the king
can't really come up
but this the problem is that you can't
bring your own king up because then
there's king c4
king moves and it's still kind of
blocking your king
so that's why rook c6 is actually more
desired
let's say rook c6 king goes to d5 now
where you should
where should you go with your rook
literally you only have one spot to go
to win
hmm still haven't seen anyone say it oh
maybe one
okay i see people are finding it or zach
is just
continuously saying it and yes rook a6
is the best one because now you have
enough room for your kink to
march up if king goes to d4 king a4
if king goes here king a5 oh oh sorry
sorry sorry
check first t moves now b5 whoops
the problem was that if you play dru k5
first let's say
i do something you can't go up there
because
king c4 check and you can't really push
b5
because i mean your rook falls so that's
kind of the little issue with this
that's kind of the dilemma so you wanted
to do rook c6
and then continue by rook a6 you want to
bring up your king
if he just kind of does a waiting move
you still bring the king but now
you have kind of this b5 coming up oops
check first and then b5 and then this is
kind of easier because you just
move up with your kink and if you get
checked you can simply go king b4
and enter k6 coming up at some point
if you're close to a1 you can easily
just go c8
and you just want to push this pawn king
d6
b6 this is winning
any questions before we end our two-hour
session for today
everybody doing good had some nice queen
sacrifice
some cool transition to end game and a
lot of great and puzzles
i will be sharing this link with you on
leachat
um so feel free to enjoy that
this link will be on the
videos right below the video
so feel free to have a fun a lot of fun
with the puzzles that are included that
we didn't get to
and make sure to join me for accepting
viewer challenges
tomorrow on twitch and have a great rest
of your day
[Music]
bye
you